I had a very interesting time at prom
I still happen to go with a [guy] [to] [prom] but I also had a girlfriend at [the] time we were closeted our
Family and our friends didn't know we would never have gone to prom [with] each other
[I] wish more than anything that I could go back and [redo] my prom
We here at Buzzfeed like so many of you believe that everyone [should] have the [freedom] to express who they [are] and who they love
Especially when it comes to celebrations like pong which should include the lGBTQ community [I] do go to my high school prom
[I] didn't even think it was a possibility to go with a girl because [I] hadn't seen [that] as an option and I didn't think
That it [would] ever be something safe that I could do yeah my prom experience was really
Straight um I went to a private Christian high school that was very much uniform and all kind of the same very
Conservative it was very much a closeted experience for me there weren't any openly lGbt people
I really went to wear a suit or a tuxedo or some sort and my mom said that if I was going to prom I
Had to wear a dress and I said you know what well I'm not gonna wear a dress [in] because that's not who I am
[I] made a choice [not] to go to prom trying to show my mom that this is [who] I am if I did wear a
Suit I do
Know that I still would [have] been that is inclusive as you know everyone else feels when they're at prom I remember seeing like probably
one or two
Queer couples at my prom. I remember thinking that I was very scared about drawing that kind of attention to myself
I felt like I wasn't ready
I
Happen to have gone with a girl even though [I] knew that
I was gay it was kind of something that I was doing just to make other people happy
I've never been a big person about dances
But that's because I never felt welcome in those spaces even like super out queer people were
Not going with Same-sex partners. I do remember how I'm come from [my] phone and how
Like not cute. I thought right, and it's because I was wearing [this] tux and I felt very like robotic
I look back on pictures
And [I] like [to]
[cry] and I think that it has a lot to do with the fact that I've come to realize and accept that I'm trans and
Then I would have much rather
Appreciated wearing a dress and had my hair up and had a bunch of makeup on had I seen
Other queer students accepting themselves and being comfortable with their partners and with their identities
It would have helped me come to my realisation much sooner as shown by the personal stories of even just the people who work here
many schools continue to discourage and even exclude
LGBTQ students from their own problems crom represents the right to experience an important and Joyous event and it should be without discrimination
[I] successfully went to prom with my girlfriend at the time
Everybody around us was super supportive when I see young kids having problems
Taking whoever they want it's so heartbreaking for me because I [think] that was a really
Defining moment in my coming-out journey my high school prom experience was extraordinary myself
No dropping at the time going to prom together
Which was the first time in the history of my high school that I had ever been done?
So needless to say it was a bit heavy
Before the prom starts we all gather in her high [school] auditorium
And you get a walk out on stage
holding the hand of your date and there were questions about whether we would just go directly to prom my answer to [that] was a
Resounding fuck [now] of course. I'm walking out holding her hand and I am so grateful for that experience. I know that. It helped shape
Exactly who I am today when I was in high school
I went to five proms
with five straight women and
Never once did I [see] a same-sex couple there when I think about the problems that I've been to in the past and the problems
That still lie ahead. [I] think it's so important that we celebrate our differences
[we're] here to announce that buzzfeed is throwing queer prom [a] night where people of all sexual
Orientations and Gender identities can celebrate prom the way it should [be] inclusive diverse
fabulous
Homo Normativity Fashion glamorous gay
pride everyone coming together
being one we wanted to be available to people who need it most [a] group of people who contact us will be flown out to
Los angeles to attend the event and to star in a special buzzfeed video series
Please follow the link below to learn [more] information about our prom and how to access other resources
For lGbt youth [we] hope that through this experience
We can shine a light on how prom should be [welcomed] to
Everyone and that means including people who are changing the future for the better. We're talking about you
now
everybody dance
oh
fine food food, please leather Daddy were
Super Queer [unicorns] dancing these are not at the tip suits dresses rainbows who the fuck cares what you want?